I
hey guys merry here at TGS 2015 and
we're gonna do a show floor we're gonna
see everything there is to see and what
a better place to start than Kaname he's
showing off Metal Gear Online main edit
we may need you if there's any good
description for the Tokyo Game Show it's
probably entertainment pretty much every
booth here is meant to grab your
attention and entertain you for as long
as I can possibly keep you around which
means lots of flashing lights lots of
colors and lots of dancing
okay one of my favorite things are
coming to Japan is the fact that they're
so into attack on titan here you will
find products everywhere for attack on
titan from the game to the series itself
and yes they are letting you change your
face and make you become a Titan it is
creepy it's probably more creepy than
entertaining let's do it
we're gaming is back and better than
ever this year they're going big because
they have world of warships that just
released but they're also showing off
world of tank also here at TGS is twitch
and I'm here with John carnage has going
it's going well I'm here it feels right
um I'm huge out here by the way they
call me John Zilla not just joncarnage
so when I could switch doing all the
time here's so we're doing a bunch of
stuff right now as you can see there's
my own one of my favorite musicians for
gaming music he did a pixel junkie Eden
the music for the background stuff he's
one of the best indie music artists out
there so he's up there talking about a
new game that he's working on a
collaboration with other gentlemen and
so yeah that typical kind of stuff that
you would see on stage what's a bunch of
other cool stuff aww have a good time
John you see all right let's get going
King go another unexpected thing at TGS
with strike oh here's a giant display
where he's actually interacting with
people let's go check it out oh let's go
from gamespot he was sleeping when we
came over here and a bunch of people
walked up and he stretched and he got up
and he came over it's this is the
awesome I just wish we had the game go
reach out and try to pet him
looks like we're seeing some dark souls
3 at the PlayStation booth they're
showing off a lot right now they've got
blood-borne new expansion I think it's
called the old hunters there's also
gravity days which used to be on Vita
now it's coming to consoles as well as a
few other surprises so let's go see what
they're showing
thank you
a lot of people were hoping to play
persona 5 at TGS and unfortunately all
they got was a trailer and a delayed
release date but nevertheless you can
see the brand new trailer for persona 5
over here being spliced with footage
from odin sphere towards the back of
Square Enix you'll see final fantasy 14
this is the battle arena heavens Ward
you'll see a line all the way wrapped
around and that's because if you win you
are gifted a t-shirt and some in-game
items at the Bandai Namco booth which
you can see is absolutely enormous
couple of cool things here is a God
Eater resurrection virtual booth where
you can see a giant virtual gun and then
shoot it it's pretty wild I think it's
probably more interesting when you're in
that booth and you can actually see the
3d replica scale of these massive guns
and to the right you'll see a life size
scale of a Gundam head this is a one to
one replica of a helmet complete with I
shinji day
monster hunter is huge here in the east
and they have a massive display for both
monster hunter x and monster hunter
stories they're a little different I've
been playing a little bit a monster
runner at home so I'm actually pretty
stoked to try this out but it always
ends up coming through the West much
later
we'll get a quick look here at phoenix
wright ace attorney 6 the entire booth
is a recreation of the court where you
actually do your battles at the back of
capcom we are also showing off umbrella
corpse you can get a chance to test out
the game in the back in a cage
biohazard is actually showing off a real
shooting range in order to promote
umbrella corpse I can't believe they got
permission to have this it's incredibly
intimidating being in here but this is
exactly where you're able to try out the
different pellet guns that they have
they have them all out on the wall so
you can see what you want and then go
ahead and fire at the shooting range
ahead
one of the most spectacular booths this
year has to go to grand blue fantasy who
have recreated an enormous ship and
they've even stocked it with people
dressed head to toe and the most perfect
costumes they're spectacular they're
gorgeous
the Star Wars Battlefront booth is
pretty much a massive spectacle showing
off 64 players and the large 64 player
map all battling it out
so that's pretty much the entire show
floor for Tokyo Game Show 2015 thanks
for joining me you guys we're gonna have
a lot more to show you guys over the
next few days so be sure to stay tuned
to gamespot
you